one two three go hello there and welcome
to conan o'brien needs a friend
this is a crisp professional opening of
the show
i've been criticized always well i was
criticized
last week and i got in my head because
you guys were saying
that uh i overthink the opening i take a
long pause so today i just jumped in
it's been one minute well i think so far
have i addressed the note matt do you
think
yeah i i actually think this energy
you're coming in with right now is right
in the sweet spot let's ride
it okay well i'm going to keep going
with this crisp and officious tone
uh the dow industrial average uh has
uh has plunged what uh we are seeing a
cold front no
moving across the midwest rather
late in the year for that but we think
it's because of a high pressure zone
in the arctic region it's drawing cooler
air north
that is not what this is and uh still of
course
uh we see as the planets revolve and
they're majestic
no no dances podcasts we say things like
vagiroo
yeah so you're saying that i'm
projecting history
originally it originated here yeah we
had sound effects theater
uh on this that's a big hit we got to
bring that back
yeah we got to bring sound to fix
theater back uh i played that one
for my kids and they were my kids are
not
fans of my work nor should they be but
they really liked sound effects theater
that was kind of sad what my kids are
not fancy no no well i don't train them
not to be
i've always wanted them to aim higher
the immigrant dream
is you want your kids to be better and
do better than you did and so my people
came to this country from ireland
and then each generation tried to push
the next generation further
so i need my children to sort of have
some level of disdain for what i do
that makes sense and then um work at a
bank well that's the plan
i like them both to work at uh banks not
anything bad i want them to be at the
towers
yeah tellers okay tellers at banks i
don't if they get higher than that then
they're sort of responsible for the
rapacious greed that's destroying our
country
but if they're a teller they're like
here's a lollipop because you just
opened an account
yes that's nice yeah here's do you want
the leather checkbook or do you want the
fake leather checkbook
um you know that seems good here's a
calendar do they still give calendars at
banks i don't
think so do they give calendars at banks
i haven't been in a bank in
30 years i don't know you know when i
first
came to los angeles with greg daniels in
1985
and we went to sunset gower studios and
we worked there
as comedy writers on a show called not
necessarily the news they then gave us
our paycheck after a week
and greg and i walked to the bank and i
remembered going
into the bank and just thinking like
what is this because it was my first job
my first real job and walking in to open
an account and deposit it there
and then they told me you know you don't
have to do this anymore there's a
machine out there you put it in the
envelope
huh do you remember this yeah well i
don't remember i wasn't there
no no but you remember i know you
weren't there oh i wasn't there either
yeah well gorilla you may have been
there you're kind of a weird guy i
remember there was a weird little kid in
glasses and shorts
who was wearing an i like ike button who
was following me around
and he said someday we're going to work
together on a future version of
radio you'll see and then you took out a
little ukulele and you went a dodea
[Music]
they never let me back in i remember
that little kid in shorts
i met you girly see you'll hear from me
soon mr o'brien
i'll punch you in the gullet i'm gonna
punch you right in the kneecap cause
that's as high as i can reach
but someday i'll have a craftsman-style
home
and a lot of mid-century furniture
and then i'll show you all and then you
took out your ukulele again
dab dab don't you totally don't need
them you
i'm going to have all kinds of special
pottery
made in the late 50s that i'm going to
buy at a rose bowl
swap me and i'm going to have some felt
hats that i rarely get to wear because
temperatures are too high in pasadena
one more song
did you know eisenhower had two strokes
in office look kid get lost
i thought you'd like that i do like it
kid but i got stuff to do i'm just
getting started in comedy and i've gotta
do well enough
so i can one day have a podcast okay off
to buy a ripoff eames chair bye
i'm gonna get on my 50s vintage schwinn
bicycle now
a weenic walker sure needs oil
then you tried to play the ukulele while
you were driving and you
you crashed i did have a schwinn i had a
schwinn tornado
you did with a big basket up front
and it was filled with original
documents from the 1920s
okay let's start this goddamn show all
right let's get this show started